my sound optimistic is because I am
today our lines remains a bulwark of
Global Security and stability as has
been for more than seven decades NATO is
stronger more energized and yes more
united than ever in its history indeed
more vital to our shared future
it didn't happen by accident it wasn't
inevitable when Putin and his Craven
lust for land and power unleashes brutal
war on Ukraine he was betting NATO would
break apart
he was betting NATO would break
he thought our Unity would shatter at
the first testing he thought Democratic
leaders would be weak
but he thought wrong
after nearly a year and a half of
Russia's forces committed terrible
atrocities including crimes against
humanity the people of Ukraine remain
unbroken Unbroken
Ukraine remains independent it remains
straight
and the United States has built a
coalition of more than 50 Nations
to make sure Ukraine defends itself both
now and is able to do it in the future
as well I mean that our commitment to
Ukraine will not weaken we will stand
for Liberty and freedom today tomorrow
and for as long as it takes
a
h
will be positive
[Music]
or not
uh
Venom
at the Munich security conference in
February I called for long-term security
Arrangements to protect Ukraine break
the cycle of Russian violence and
ultimately help end this war
and today we have delivered
together with our G7 Partners we have
agreed to provide the long-term
bilateral security commitments that
Ukraine needs
these commitments Mark a new high point
in international support for Ukraine
and I want to be clear they are not a
substitute for NATO membership
the summit communique Echoes the UK's
long-held position that Ukraine's future
is in NATO
and we've taken a big step this week
towards bringing Ukraine into the
alliance
together we've shortened their path to
membership removing the need for a
membership action plan and holding the
first meeting of the NATO Ukraine
council with President zielinski sitting
at the table by our side as an equal is
foreign